>>> WELCOME BACK.
I'M MICHAEL HOLMES.
WE ARE FOLLOWING REPORTS OF
SEVERAL ARRESTS IN JORDAN DURING
A SECURITY SWEEP.
ALSO THE FORMER CROWN PRINCE
SAYS IN A VIDEO STATEMENT THAT
HE'S BEEN PUT IN ISOLATION AND
HIS COMMUNICATIONS ARE BEING CUT
OFF.
PRINCE HAMZAH bin HUSSEIN IS THE
SON OF THE LATE KING HUSSEIN AND
HE IS KING ABDULLAH'S HALF
BROTHER.
HE SAYS HE'S NOT PART OF ANY
CONSPIRACY BUT THAT THE KINGDOM
HAS BECOME CORRUPT.
HERE'S MORE OF HIS STATEMENT.
>> I HAD A VISIT FROM THE CHIEF
OF THE GENERAL STAFF OF
JORDANIAN ARMED FORCES THIS
MORNING.
IN WHICH HE INFORMED ME THAT I
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO GO OUT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PEOPLE OR TO
MEET WITH THEM BECAUSE THAT IN
THE MEETINGS THAT I HAD BEEN
PRESENT IN OR ON SOCIAL MEDIA
RELATING TO VISITS I'VE MADE
THERE'S BEEN CRITICISM OF THE
GOVERNMENT OR THE KING.
>> CNN IS FOLLOWING THE STORY
FROM ISTANBUL, TURKEY.
THE WORLD TENDS TO TAKE
STABILITY THERE FOR GRANTED.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY TO HAVE A
FORMER CROWN PRINCE UNDER
DETENTION.
WHAT DO YOU READ BEHIND THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, MICHAEL, IT IS
VERY, VERY MURKY AT THIS POINT.
WE REALLY DO NOT KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON.
BASICALLY REPORTS EMERGED LATE
ON SATURDAY THAT THERE HAD BEEN
SOME SORT OF A PLOT IN JORDAN,
SOME SORT OF A SECURITY
OPERATION AND THAT SENIOR
FIGURES INCLUDING THE FORMER
CROWN PRINCE, PRINCE HAMZAH bin
HUSSEIN HAD BEEN ARRESTED OR
UNDER HOUSE ARREST AND GOT A
STATEMENT FROM THE CHIEF OF THE
JORDANIAN MILITARY BASICALLY
SAYING THAT -- DENYING REPORTS
THAT PRINCE HAMZAH WAS NOT
ARRESTED, BUT HE WAS BASICALLY
TOLD TO TONE IT DOWN, THAT THEY
HAD ASKED HIM NOT TO TAKE PART
IN ANY ACTIVITIES OR MOVEMENTS
AS THEY DRY-NUARY DESCRIBED THAT
COULD BE EXPLOITED TO TRY TO
DESTABILIZE THE COUNTRY AND SAID
THIS WAS PART OF THE BIGGER
SECURITY OPERATION ONGOING WHERE
SEVERAL HIGH-PROFILE FIGURES IN
THE KINGDOM INCLUDING A JUNIOR
MEMBER OF THE ROYAL FAMILY AND A
FORMER VERY WELL-KNOWN AND
SENIOR OFFICIAL WITHIN KING
ABDULLAH'S CIRCLES HAD ALSO BEEN
DETAINED AS PART OF THE SWEEP
AND SEVERAL OTHERS AND SAID IT
IS AN ON GOING INVESTIGATION AND
MORE WILL BE RELEASED.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT WE GOT THIS
STUNNING VIDEO OBTAINED BY THE
BBC FROM PRINCE HAMZAH TALKING
ABOUT HIS SITUATION BASICALLY
SAYING THAT HE IS ESSENTIALLY
UNDER HOUSE ARREST AND TOLD NOT
TO LEAVE HIS HOME AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND SECURITY HAD
BEEN CUT OFF AND TAKEN AWAY AND
THIS IS HIS LAST FORM OF
COMMUNICATION.
HIS SATELLITE WILL BE CUT OFF
AND SHOCKING FOR MANY JORDANIANS
AND ALSO IN THE REGION AS YOU
MENTIONED, A COUNTRY THAT IS ONE
OF THE MORE STABLE IN THIS
REGION.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING,
YOU KNOW, IN HIS VIDEO MESSAGE
WHICH WE SHOULD POINT OUT
NOTABLY IT IS IN ENGLISH THAT HE
IS, YOU KNOW, NOT A PARTY TO ANY
CONSPIRACY BUT THEN GOES ON TO
POINTLY CRITICIZE CORRUPTION,
BREAKDOWN IN GOVERNANCE,
INCOMPETENCE IN THE GOVERNING --
TALKED ABOUT NEPOTISM AND
MISRULE AND THOSE ARE FAIRLY
EXTRAORDINARY CRITICISMS.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
MICHAEL, TO BE HEARING THIS FROM
A MEMBER OF THE JORDANIAN ROYAL
FAMILY.
WHATEVER DISPUTES THEY MIGHT
HAVE BEHIND THE SCENES WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THIS IS TRULY UNPRECEDENTED IN
JORDAN.
WE HAVE TO POINT OUT THAT, YES,
IT IS IN ENGLISH BUT ALSO
RELEASED ANOTHER ONE TO AN ARAB
NETWORK AND ALSO AIRED LAST
NIGHT IN ARABIC AND IT SEEMS TO
BE ADDRESSING THE JORDANIAN
NATION REALLY.
I MEAN, MICHAEL, YOU KNOW, THE
BIG NEWS INTERNATIONALLY HERE
WOULD BE THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
FORMER CROWN PRINCE TALKING
ABOUT HIS CURRENT SITUATION, HIS
APPARENT HOUSE ARREST AND WHAT
IS GOING ON IN JORDAN BUT WHAT
HE SAYS AFTER THAT LASHING OUT
AT THE COUNTRY'S LEADERSHIP
WITHOUT NAMING KING ABDULLAH
TALKING MORE ABOUT THE
LEADERSHIP REALLY AND THE RULING
SYSTEM IN JORDAN, THIS IS WHAT
IS STUNNING FOR SO MANY
JORDANIANS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO ONE PART OF
THAT VIDEO STATEMENT.
>> I'M NOT THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BREAKDOWN IN
GOVERNANCE FOR THE CORRUPTION
AND FOR THE INCOMPETENCE THAT
HAS BEEN PREVALENT IN OUR
GOVERNING STRUCTURE FOR THE LAST
15 TO 20 YEARS AND HAS BEEN
GETTING WORSE BY THE YEAR.
>> Reporter: AND, YOU KNOW,
PERHAPS, MICHAEL, THIS IS ONE OF
THE MORE DIPLOMATIC STATEMENTS
THAT HE MAKES IN THAT
SIX-PLUS-MINUTE VIDEO STATEMENT.
HE REALLY, REALLY CRITICIZED THE
RULING STRUCTURE, WHAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY AND
LISTENING TO IT COMING FROM
SOMEONE LIKE PRINCE HAMZAH IS
STUNNING.
THIS IS WHAT YOU HEAR FROM
JORDANIANS ON THE STREETS, SO
MANY HAVE VOICED ABOUT IT, THE
SHRINKING SPACE FOR FREEDOM
WHERE BASICALLY NO ONE IS
ALLOWED TO IN BE THE PRESENCE OF
OTHERS WHILE THEY CRITICIZE THE
GOVERNMENT OR THE KING.
TALKING ABOUT RAMPANT CORRUPTION
IN THE COUNTRY, THE STATE OF
PUBLIC SERVICES IN THE COUNTRY
WHERE JORDAN AT ONE POINT WAS A
LEADER AND WHERE IT STANDS RIGHT
NOW.
SO THIS IS REALLY SOMETHING THAT
HITS AT THE GRIEVANCES OF SO
MANY JORDANIANS RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A COUNTRY WHERE
DISCONTENT HAS BEEN GROWING OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
STATE OF THE ECONOMY AND LIVING
CONDITIONS PRETTY MUCH IN JORDAN
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, THE
ECONOMIC FALLOUT FROM TH